thank you now to present the awards for
special effects the beautiful Israeli
actress miss hiya Harry better known as
Ben's her
in this magic land of the magic lantern
the world calls movies only few things
are impossible and when the impossible
is demanded it is always the special
effect men who bring it about the
magicians nominated for the wizardry of
special effects this past year are a
Arnold Gillespie and Robert McDonald
visual effects
Milo Laurie sound effects for Ben Hur
and LB Abbott and James B Gordon visual
effects called Faulkner's sound effects
for The Journey to the Center of the
Earth
the winner is visual effects but by a
Arnold the lesbian Robert McDonald Ben
Hur sound effects for Milo Laurie
may I speak special-effects men it was a
great honor to work on Ben Hur and this
is the proudest moment of our lives
thank you
ladies and gentlemen this is really a
very thrilling experience one which
comes very seldom the most people and
I'm very grateful to all those that are
responsible for this great honor thank
you said I simply want to point out that
the effects is never a one-man job and
there many many too numerous to mention
who should whose name should be
mentioned and who should receive the
credit my gratitude of my thanks to them
and to you